you don't remember my name oh god oh god
oh Julie this is that if you want to
make it in YouTube you gotta learn
people's names see people like T people
say your names that's why I got stuck in
my head my name is Greg Greg Greg AG
Flags bag Segway
so we landed in Zurich and they don't
have our luggage this is a an Instagram
post or a V log we'll see what happens
they lost a lot of people's luggage
including Jason organs and you know so
Jason yeah what's your channel damn feel
like I might have seen you before
tailing none of us have our suits so we
can't really go to opening night
so we're gonna find some weed and
cocaine in Switzerland tonight and see
how that order how they party it up this
is the view from Jason Hortons room he's
get a much better view than I do
bastard so Jason and I just take it
romantic we're taking a romantic stroll
little 360 panoramic view for you we
don't know if they're gonna let us into
the event cuz I don't have our seats so
we're just like [ __ ] it we'll just walk
yeah it's because we don't even know if
we're gonna get in now the meantime
we're gonna be able to check out this
place so there's some erotic stuff over
it stored it's a porn theater
holy crap the poor mob
now he'll lose the romantic side and
this is the lustful side
[Music]
[Applause]
Jason and I made it so now we just gotta
figure out how to get in let us see with
our tuxedos it's behind that bus over
there you'll see it in a second don't
recognize us we did it Jason and I made
it we walk forever found the rest of the
band we fell in love yeah these guys are
you gotta like a legit GoPro my girl
president my luggage bastards we're
gonna go watch this movie called good
fortune right now I got a terrific
behind me she's apparently just a
vlogger sells herself short I'm just the
guy who talks essentially the same yeah
look how handsome this guy is perfectly
chiseled like the cheekbones and the
facial hair do you look like you look so
sharp it's amazing good fortune dance
for us dance for us in public she said
she said she said oh this is Todd he's a
director but he's good-looking enough to
be in front of the camera
Gregor Craig Craig Craig with the jr.
channel so be good for when I dye my
hair
reduces hair fall by 71% is a good
number so those are good numbers those
are really good helpers hi Fabien mimimi
great job on the documentary I thought
was really fantastic and inspiring a
question for JP this this documentary
does cover a lot of your work ethic and
your philosophies your mentality and I
feel that a lot of people will make a
lot of excuses for themselves based off
their upbringing their experiences of
why they can't achieve success I'm
curious to know as to what kind of
personal development did you do that
allowed you to develop such a mentality
even despite the circumstances you were
dealt
good question usually good okay okay
well it's 7 years old the variety boys
club our brother and I made a flower box
carried around door-to-door to be sold
at birthdays 50 Cent's of May the
quarter when I was 11 years old and a
paper route and to build my la examiner
morning paper route bigger I would walk
my brother would go up we go not in
Georgia during our paper route to get
more customers so he got more money at
the end of the month I think we made
about 30 32 dollars a month selling
papers but we knew it could be done so
it was really personal development I
think the most personal is I've ever
received and I wish I could do today if
I could do today every one of my kids
would have to do it for a month or two
as soon as they got out of school they'd
have to do it that's selling
encyclopedias door-to-door no
appointment no one
you're coming that is touch so most of
my personal development was hi I'd like
to tell you about clothes so eventually
you learn little by little what to state
how to state a little easier a little
more interesting still want to come on
inside you give a presentation that I
learned that now 400 doors are slamming
your face you have to be just as the
thews e astok I door number 101 that's a
big secret of success be prepared for a
lot of rejection because if you are when
it comes along so that could hurt you
the heart so much you could continue on
and then do all the things other people
don't want to do well they say no no no
not when you're out of money you're out
of money if people leave like I did with
Paul Mitchell the products you had
aren't that good all you gotta do is
talk to enough of thousands of people at
one or two the hairstylist will buy from
you they'll use and say wow this is
really good stuff
then your to the reorder business so
self development though there were two
books when I sold encyclopedias I read
that were very very good there's 70 80
years old with her still bestsellers one
is how to win friends and influence
people priceless book priceless but the
other was Think and Grow originally on
aria these are great neglected I mean
with people thinking your way through
things no matter how much other things
are but I don't think there's anything
out there I've ever read or heard about
that tells you if you keep on your up
and then you go down you're up you go
down you keep on going down things are
really tough how to keep on overcoming
rejection that's something you've got to
know about if you know you have a lot of
rejection what it happens obviously
second urge is much thank you
yeah try McDonald's Switzerland food
John Flixster